Unreal Engine has always fundamentally been a game engine.
However, the real-time capabilities of Unreal
has allowed us to create more immersive experiences,
especially as it relates to real-time experiences
or in-the-moment experiences.
Unreal Engine not only allows
us to build rich and immersive worlds,
but also provides us a rich toolset
for creating those experiences.
On screen, you'll see a few examples
of how Unreal allows us to build worlds, some
of the tools at our disposal for building those worlds,
as well as tools that allow us to ship games simultaneously
on multiple platforms.
Now, while this slide is an oversimplification
of the game development process, the key principle
to take away is that game development is typically
a very fluid process.
Game development often requires changes
to be made during and even after production.
Additionally, most modern games
have some degree of live ops or ongoing content release,
be they new in-game content, DLC, seasonal content,
or patches.
So in a nutshell, game development
is a very fluid process and requires
you to think more systematically about the way
you build systems and content prior to and after release.